so you're on a role with this shaft and
yet you hated the director John
Singleton is that true or false that's
false that is false you will work with
him again you fighting with him so much
that was a whole creative kind of uh
chaos sometimes that was you know kind
of kind of going on because you had the
producers who had one idea about what
shaft is was should be then you had John
who was like a three-year-old kid when
he saw it and then you had me who
thought he could be sha because I was
basically 20 years old when saw it right
and shaft would to me is it shouldn't be
Superman he's just a guy who's very very
capable who was up against a lot of
tough situations and managed to somehow
uh Prevail yeah had some very good
Street smarts was very cool had some you
know Mac ability with the ladies and you
didn't want to make it a cartoon
character and they did exactly